We take a lot of our daily habits for granted,
don’t we?
We often forget that almost
everything we use is regulated by laws.
But when politicians create laws
that affect 450 million citizens,
what source of information
can they rely on?
Who can they trust?
Since 1957
we have been providing policymakers
with the facts that help them decide.
We look into everything
that impacts society and our well-being,
and we anticipate
the trends that will shape Europe.
Our labs count a diverse mix of scientists
who excel in their fields
and collaborate with the best
research institutes in the world.
Through the short-term lens
of news and social commentary,
the world might look troubled...
But the future becomes clearer
when we take the long-term view
of science and knowledge.
Opinion and influence
cannot shape a political agenda...
But healthy scientific discussion,
transparency and continuous study
can lead to better policies for all.
We are the Joint Research Centre
of the European Commission.
We provide independent,
evidence-based knowledge and science,
supporting EU policies
to positively impact society.